nearly twenty years ago Oprah
revolutionized reading when she created
remember this Oprah's Book Club it was
huge since then 74 titles have earned
her coveted stamp of approval and now
CBS this morning is very proud to
announce that we are collaborating with
her as she reveals her latest pick
morning Gayle
Charlie Norah I wish I was sitting there
were you guys but I have to tell you I'm
filming a movie and couldn't be there in
person but I'm thrilled to be able to
through the miracle a videotape be able
to share with you my next book club
selection
it's the Underground Railroad by Colson
whitehead now I'd never read a Colson
whitehead novel I picked it up did what
I normally do read the first line see if
the first line gets me the first time
Caesar approached kora about running
north
she said no this was her grandmother
talking and I was in and I'm so glad I
went in and stayed in because this is I
have to say one of the most grim
gripping powerful novels about slavery I
have ever experienced and I use the word
experienced because the read is a
journey that you take with all of the
characters but at the end you feel a
sense of inspiration strengthened by the
story their story and a sense of power I
think no better book for a time such as
this and I'm really excited that all of
your viewers will be able to experience
the latest book club selection the
Underground Railroad by Colson whitehead
that's a nice introduction you got it
straight from the source Oprah's new
book club selection is the Underground
Railroad by Colson white hood goes on
sale today and guess what Colson is here
at the table hello Colson Mike
let me tell you something at the
magazine Li Haber who's our book editor
is always looking for a book she sends
over books constantly that she reads and
it's always nope nope nope no it took
over a year and a half and Lee came in
and said Oprah likes it she likes it she
likes it she said that it was an
emotional read for her I'm wondering if
it was as emotional for you to write it
well I think in general about the book
I'm done with the book and I want to
think about it and for the first time
I've gone back to different passages
this chapter that passage and really
rewriting it and how emotional it was
and how powerful was to to narrate
Cora's story so it's a different
experience for me ever since I finished
it and then giving it the people my
editor and my agent the response has
been just so different than new you've
never written about race and slavery and
in any slavery story somebody is going
to die no I mean yeah I mean race is
brutal the things I write about it's in
this book and on that book but slavery I
avoided it for a long time it seemed
very daunting subject my first came up
with the idea of the book sixteen years
ago I was sitting on my couch and I
think a lot of people when they first
hear about the Underground Railroad when
you're a kid they think it's a liberal
subway yeah and then you hear about it's
not any sort of disappointed and so I
was I was thinking what if the
Underground Railroad actually was a
literal railroad and took it from there
and that's a premise it's not really a
story so I kept thinking about it and I
was thinking what if every state our
protagonist goes through as he or she
goes North is a different state of
American possibility and so it became
sort of Gulliver's travel type structure
and what was your reaction when you
learned that Oprah had chosen you and
your book as part of its book club well
you know I try to keep a downcast
demeanour and depressive the last four
months you know we found out in April
I've just been in a good mood I'm at the
supermarket supermarket and the cashier
is like paper or plastic I'm like where
you going bud and I'm like
that's the only she calls the author
yeah she couldn't call you because you
were on a plane oh yeah I was traveling
and so I couldn't get that um that
iconic moment but we landed then I got a
voicemail from my agent and usually when
an agent my agent calls me I'm in
trouble or something so I was a worried
man what you said Oprah and I was like
shut the front door and and then she
said Oprah's Book Club and I said and he
blank and then everyone's looking at me
because I was on an airplane and when
TSA didn't take me off set and here yeah
you ever says that there's a revival in
interest in slavery and the implications
of slavery well I think as you know I'm
sort of in the moment so I can step back
and figure out why there's django
unchained and twelve years a slave and
why the popular or roots I couldn't
watch the roots reboot I'm sort of
slavery doubt at the moment so one day I
might go back to it but I think as we
get more african-american writers and
directors and actors and get more access
were able to tell our own stories and
the number Justin people like easy coach
they're talking about it others yeah I
mean you know some people point to
Ferguson and black lives matter for me
what those movements are addressing in
those moments it's not really it's not
really news to me
and so I think it's entering a taking up
a larger space and in the America's
consciousness but I think if you're
black American you sort of know all this
already and when you talked about to
being a father Coulson how it includes
the writing of this book in particular
yeah well I think when I had the idea I
was in my early 30s and kind of a genic
slacker just goofing off all day and I
wasn't able to you know tackle the book
and never a couple years I would revisit
the idea am I ready now and then working
something else and then I think becoming
older and you know becoming a father I
understood what it was like in a new way
to say see your parent your child beaten
killed tortured
taken away from you taken away for you I
was more able to inhabit that feeling in
a way that I could when I was younger so
I think was good to wait I think I
became a better writer about 16 years
and so in terms of my ability I think I
was able to do a better job and I would
have done 16 years ago and I think I'm
you know as a person I think I was more
able to take it on
well Congrats like the days have been
over for a long time yes maybe you and I
should do a facebook live a couple weeks
from now that sounds after people give
people a chance to read it and then we
can talk to you and that sounds really
thank you because my good thing thank
you so much and go to CBS this morning
calm for a reader's guide and an excerpt
from the Underground Railroad which goes
on sale today plus there are more bonus
features and don't miss Oprah's
interview with Colson whitehead it's in
the September issue of what's the
magazine or
also on newsstands next Tuesday August
night